In today's society it is more and more
often required that we are awake at night.
It may be because of shift work.
It may be because we are studying very hard
for an exam.
To really understand what is
happening when you're pulling such an
all-nighter is important because society:
your boss wants you to be awake at night/
your biological clock want you to sleep
at that particular time.
Almost all organisms on Earth use internal
biological clocks called circadian clocks
to help them adapt to the cycle of night and day.
As humans we have a circadian clock
in our brain that among
other things helps us to stay alert and awake
during the day and to sleep at night.
So what happens when we break this cycle
and don't go to sleep at all?
Here at the University of Surrey,
in the Surrey Sleep Research Centre,
we have specialized facilities which allow us to
study the effects of pulling an all-nighter
under very controlled conditions.
The participants are kept
awake for 40 or 42 hours while you are
lying in a bed in a dimly lit room.
These bedrooms are sound attenuated, obviously
light-controlled, temperature-controlled.
We can study the cognition in these individuals.
We can simply ask them how sleepy they are.
We can draw blood samples
and then look at the rhythms in
hormones and of course we can record
their brainwaves to quantify sleep and wakefulness.
We can actually see what the biological clock
is telling to the rest of the body
and to the rest of the brain.
If you keep someone awake for 40 hours straight
and measure their alertness,
you find something surprising.
Instead of alertness dropping and getting worse
the longer someone is kept awake—
as it gets to morning on the second day of sleep
deprivation, alertness actually starts to increase again.
This is because there are
two forces controlling when we should sleep.
The first is sleep pressure, which builds up
the longer we are awake .
But the second is our circadian clock, which
drives alertness during the day
but promote sleep at night.
It's our circadian clock that gives us a fresh burst
of alertness on the second day as it stops
promoting sleep and starts promoting
wakefulness again.
So when you are a shift worker but you
don't go to sleep at ten o'clock in the
morning after your night shift but you
stay awake as the participants in our
sleep deprivation protocols do—
you will find it slightly easier the second day.
So despite you having been awake now
for 27 or 35 hours, you can stay awake easier
because the clock during the biological day
will help you to stay awake.
What do we learn from these studies?
Well, first of all, if we understand the
interaction between those circadian rhythms
and our sleep/wake cycle—
then we can design for example shift
work schedules that will lead to less
disruption of brain function.
Understanding this interaction may also
help us to understand why in certain
neurodegenerative diseases disruption of
the sleep/wake cycle is so important
and how maybe by rescuing the sleep/wake cycle,
we can ameliorate some of the
effects of those neurodegenerative diseases
or even the effects of aging itself.